il vous avez pu le constater cette
élection présidentielle devrait battre
un record celui du nombre de candidats
ils sont actuellement près d'une
vingtaine contre 9 il ya sept ans il est
vrai que tous n'auront sans doute pas
les 500 signatures nécessaires
l'une de celles en tout cas qu'on
attendait le moins et guyanaise
christiane taubira investi par les
radicaux de gauche
elle veut détonner dans la campagne
emilie lançons yade - arrivée de cayenne
en petit matin christiane taubira
traversé plusieurs fois l'océan chaque
mois c'est la première femme noire se
présenter à la présidentielle pour
gagner elle a fait le plein d'énergie
je savais que j'avais besoin de respirer
la forêt amazonienne d'entendre des
bruits de marcher nu pieds sur la terre
de prendre un bébé de mer pour sa
campagne christiane taubira va devoir
affronter le froid son tour de france
vient de commencer
elle veut avant tout se faire connaître
passage obligé dans le sud-ouest en pays
radicale la prospérité de tous les
vignerons du lot les viticulteurs sont
sous le charme puisque un oiseau des
îles et là je crois qu'il faut en
profiter
outre mer christiane publierait déchaîne
les passions à cayenne en 96
on a dansé toute la nuit lors de son
élection comme député
la politique elle l'a prise comme
indépendantiste dans les années 80 c'est
ma fierté ce militantisme indépendante y
est justement la capacité d'aller
jusqu'au bout de mes engagements parce
que la rupture était la seule réponse
possible
christiane taubira version 2002 c'est
une grosse voiture un discours
universaliste social et anti
sécuritaires c'est la france continue à
s'enfermer dans la peur et si elle y est
encouragé notamment par ses discours
ultrasécuritaire
le lien social va continuer à se
dissoudre aucune société ne construit
son avenir en se défiant de ses voisins
la candidate des radicaux de gauche
compte sur le vote des dom tom et des
banlieues mais ce n'est pas gagné
il me semble que c'est la personne qui
donne à manger gratuitement à ses seins
non pas vraiment mais après une brève
rencontre
le malentendu est dissipée christiane
taubira doit maintenant relever un autre
défi redynamiser en partie oublié